it's so interesting when men get a
vasectomy how Twitter just gets so
triggered and and I want to have an
honest conversation about this we know
that the reputation of marriage is bad
okay we know that women have a nature
okay we know that women's nature when we
tend to get power we aren't very nice
with it when we tend to get leverage we
aren't very nice with it uh my evidence
for this is in the last hundred years
when policy makers have had to cater to
women to get elected women have elected
politicians that have passed unfair
child support alimony divorce laws child
custody laws and really policies that in
my eyes only benefit women